hello everyone I'm Alex Gregorian I'm a
senior director of engineering at
Walmart labs and I was a big crowd
coming and I work on the application
platform in Walmart labs so it's kind of
a team that builds the framework that
powers the front-end experience
a lot of the orchestration layers and so
this is really about our journey and our
journey kind of through migrating to
react but more importantly about the
reusability aspects of being able to
kind of leverage react components to
reuse across different applications
different entities and so during we had
a transition from kind of this Java
stack into react the node and one of the
reasons for that transition was we
wanted to really be able to leverage
react components and reuse them across
the sites different different sites
within Walmart as well as kind of app
teams within and so we ran into lots of
challenges kind of different
complexities so this is really about our
kind of philosophies so we're gonna go
through kind of the philosophies that we
used to for our solutions and kind of go
through what solutions we used belong
with the challenges and the principles
we use to kind of go into those
solutions so the scale that we're
talking about is is relatively on large
rent so all the solutions might not work
for you based on your size based on your
needs I'm sure there's other ways to
achieve reusability so this is about
kind of how we do it and our scale I
think we currently have like 4 or 500
components 300 something engineers
across like 50 apps so if you know you
have one or two components and a dozen
folks I think a lot of our solutions
might not pertain to you but hopefully
you can at least walk away with some of
the guiding principles that we that we
used for our solutions and so we you
know this whole talk is about
reusability and it's a really key
importance for our organization
particular
because of kind of the way we're
structured and we're structured for
productivity and efficiency and what we
do is we end up breaking up every almost
most pages that are relatively large and
scoped have their own team dedicated to
them and there they have their own
cluster and so their their own
application fundamentally so homepage
item page search cart checkout they have
their own application on their own
cluster with their own team that's
focused on building features and
capabilities for them so what that means
is if we want to share a couple if you
want to reuse a component across like
home page and item page it's not like
we're sharing across two pages we're
actually sharing across two applications
so if you take on out all the pages at
Walmart that are larger in scope you
know they're obviously there's teams
that own multiple smaller pages you're
really looking at reusing components
across tons of tons of apps so if you
have something like the carousel and
Walmart loves the carousel I don't know
if you've been to our site but we have a
lot of carousels I think that the home
page had nine carousels at one point and
then we toned it down we're like too
many carousels and so we have this
carousel on the home page and item page
and category and all kinds of places and
we want to be able to reuse that across
all these places not have to rewrite it
over and over again and then you take
that and you multiply it by how many
entities we have so all of these are
different sites as well with their own
teams their own components and all of
them have carousels to every single one
right so you don't want to keep
rewriting it so then when you look into
other functionality like login although
three of them have a login they all kind
of the same thing they don't have
carousels they're like carts checkouts
item pages so while they look very
different we can actually reuse
components and the way we use so we call
this capability kind of multi-tenancy or
multi-brand and that's kind of a
separate topic of how we go about
reusing components and different
entities because they have different
styling different content and and so
I'll just touch upon it but that's kind
of one of the really big reasons that we
want to use
we want a real to reuse components and
it was such a an important aspect of our
focus and we and our framework that we
kind of open-source that all of Walmart
runs on which we call electron and and
that's why you'll see kind of the little
alien logo that's kind of the key
tenants is the ability to reuse
components and that's kind of what it's
built for and that's the key reasons why
we have that's this large focus if we
even if we have this carousel and we
don't reuse it you're gonna have like 20
developers build the same thing across
all these different apps and entities so
we let's so let's talk about the actual
solutions and problems on what we've
done that's kind of the context so we go
into the how do you actually reuse code
and the technical aspects of actually
sharing right you can't copy paste
because that's not really reusing it's
kind of like forking so the way we go
about it is all components are outside
the application all components are
developed independently outside of the
application they're on their own
repositories and so we have this we have
an organization in github we use get up
the locally run version and we have so
we have like the react component
organization and all components that are
developed are not inside the
applications there are different
repositories within this organization
that way you go to one place and you
know you can find every component that
the company is kind of building all
those components are then published to
NPM they're all version following you
know major minor patch and then apps
that want to use the component will then
npm install them so that's kind of our
method of just using components but and
so that's kind of like the first basis
that's the so the first thing that you
you know that we have to solve this well
I want that component and you want the
component how would we share it and so
this is kind of the the method that we
use to kinda go about it and the first
thing that happens is managing
dependencies as hell right like we can
have to manage all these core
dependencies libraries build systems
testing
linting and if any of them are different
in any way the app team can't reuse it
and if they can't and if there is any
inconsistency and some components versus
other components you immediately lose
the trust of the different organizations
and they might not even try to use it or
they might run it and there's like a
problem and they'll say whatever I'll
just rebuild it and so the consistency
aspect is incredibly important and one
of the key parts of being able to be
consistent is managing all the
dependencies so there's one part of
managing the dependencies and making
sure you know what versions of
everything you're using and then the
other part of managing dependencies is
how do you upgrade from like react 15.3
to 15.4 across 500 components at once
and you know do I really want to send
you use these 500 pull requests and then
you're gonna have to bump them up and
how do we then every team has to kind of
look into each component to see what
version are they're using and it becomes
very difficult very quickly so we have
this up concept that we call archetypes
and so if you ever go to the electrode
website electrode that IO you'll see
archetype mentioned a lot and it's kind
of the key pieces of the framework in
that the idea behind it is that you have
kind of one package that will consume a
lot of your other production
dependencies and your dev dependencies
and that one package is versioned and
it's and and so that way you know that
if I have you know version five point
three point two of the archetype all of
them are the same they all have the same
core libraries and so if you ever make a
change to a core library and you were
propagated across all the other
components all you do is change the
archetype and all the components will
get that propagation of depending on if
it's a patch and minor and and how
they're upgrading and and so if you want
to add a new library change libraries
move things around and how you really
manage dependencies and how teams have
trust and how things are the consistency
of the components is through the
archetype so we can talked about these
the the different entities and they how
they have how components you might want
a component for Walmart to look
different
component from Sam's Club and the way we
do that is based on the brand that you
are the component might build
differently it might pull from different
CSS files it might pull from kind of
different templates it might pull from
different content and so the components
also have to build consistently and they
have to build in a specific way so the
archetype is really the way to manage
hundreds of components is the easiest
way that that we found and so along with
for it to build consistently and for
people to for me prefer to add
consistently you also have to be able to
kind of generate the component so along
with the archetype thinking we also have
this ability to generate new components
so when you install that archetype you
can generator the components they all
look the same directory structure is the
same and it all solves other problems
and and and will kind of continue that
in another area so now that we have the
ability to reuse technically we have the
way to instill consistency so teams have
confidence on what they're getting they
can use the app we have a way to manage
dependencies we have something called a
meta team within Walmart and what's
going to happen is we have a few hundred
engineers you need a process to also
have kind of code quality consistency
general principled consistency and how
you build certain things you need and
because you're affecting so many people
you're trying to keep so many people
consistent you need ambassadors from all
other teams because you know to
communicate broadly widely you need to
be able to discuss changes and so that's
where we have this kind of meta team
concept come from so we have generally a
few people from every single team
generally the most senior people and
these folks dedicate their time to have
weekly or bi-weekly calls to discuss
things that are kind of coming up with
management components changing libraries
if we want to go a new direction and
those those individuals can then distill
that to their team's get feedback and
gives us a source to to really
communicate
we're gonna because everybody has to be
on the same page the other piece that
electrode matter does which I found
unusual but I felt like it really works
is any change that goes into that react
components organization and github so
any component that's touched there's
generally you know react metal folk they
can elect Road meta folks that will own
those components and they'll always be
there to review them and give feedback
give insight and this really helps
promote that that discussion and make
sure things don't fall through the
cracks because with so many people and
trying to keep everyone on the same page
things will fall through the cracks
there'll be new engineers that might not
know certain things or might be trying
to do something and so it's really you
have all these ambassadors from other
teams that you can use to communicate as
well as they can Shepherd everyone else
and we have something called the
proposal process so with all these
components you're definitely going to
get people that you're gonna definitely
want to get possibly duplicates of
components and you're gonna want to
change direction maybe of upgrading a
library or you have a problem and how do
you want to solve that problem and so a
lot of these problems and and things
that we want to really get feedback from
our internal community we have a github
proposal process where someone will put
up a proposal for a direction or a
change that they want to do or for a new
component that they want to build and
the API is around that component and
like the patina like there's in terms of
the prop types and the interfaces and
and what they want to use it for and
this gives this really encourages
discussion across the other teams to
discuss like oh I'm gonna need that
component as well and can you and you
know can we modify the interface to be
more generic or or what not so before
every components kind of created in ours
we have the system to ensure that the
engineers first can talk to others that
it's all transparent and open and there
could be a collaborative discussion and
it does add a little bit of overhead and
I'll kind of get into the challenges of
that and one of the last kind of pieces
of problems of discovery we if we have
all these components it becomes very
difficult to discover what components
you
and what you need it becomes difficult
to find out if is there you know some
kind of video player or component or not
especially if they're not named properly
especially if you might have a Caribe oh
with multiple components so for the
discovery process we have kind of this
tool called electrode Explorer which we
open sourced as well and it basically
runs all the components in our
organization
you know understood web application that
way anybody can kind of sift through
every component look at the
documentation its dependencies
dependencies that it uses view it modify
and like a little there's a little
prayer playground where you can modify
the prop types and and use its interface
so you can really see how it functions
see if it fits your needs now for this
to work it goes back to all components
have to have a consistent way to
showcase this so they all have to have
the ability to showcase a playground
they all have to have a demo app and so
that so even to do this that archetype
kind of comes into play where it's
really entangled into every kind of
piece and process that we have because
the archetype ensures that all the apps
have a demo it ensures that all the
applications can build the same they can
build in a way for this demo to work and
for them to show up on electrode
Explorer so that's why the archetype is
kind of this fundamental foundation for
us to move forward and so that's how we
went about solving discovery then we
gave this to product teams designers
that way everyone now has a library
fundamentally that gets built naturally
as you build components change
components and you can go back through
the versions of the components and
people now are on kind of the same page
of what do you have what can I use and
designers also have something to
leverage and what's really interesting
is if you have a product team that you
want to showcase some components that
you've built - all you do is send them
links to explore and they'll be able to
see it and play with it and validate if
it's you know if this is what they want
or not but then there's like certain
problems that we've that we've had and
that's around components breaking other
teams that's the worst thing about
having dependencies in the
usability you know the whole center
there's this reliance on other teams and
they're gonna break you and it's only a
matter of time you know that's gonna
happen and the only way that we can kind
of figure out how to solve this is
through C ICD and it actually there's it
puts a lot of you have to put a lot of
effort in building proper tests in your
application in the component so the
first pass of C ICD can be just like
component unit tests and make sure
that's solid but that doesn't guarantee
breakage because you change the
component and you make sure it works and
you probably test it on your application
and that works great but those other
apps you know who cares I got the
features to release and so there's no
real way to guarantee that so I think
the only the only way that we can think
of to really solve this problem is have
C ICD run automatically update other
applications and run their tests and run
their automation so if you push up a
surface n of PR and in the PR you can
specify is this is a new you know minor
upgrade or patch upgrade our CDC ICD
pipeline can you know wants to grab
other all other applications that use
that dependency automatically bump them
and run their automation suite and and
and kind of tell the person that's PR
and which ones are passing which ones
are failing that way before it gets
reviewed by the meta team and before it
gets accepted you can see what the
impact of that PR will do and what we
want to get to is we want to get to a
place where if things pass we want to
automatically upgrade apps that way
there's no there's no need for engineers
to even kind of go through and say oh
these things have been updated I know
they work and let me manually you know
bump up their versions but where it's
much more automated than that that way
if you will have a bug fix or some
feature improvement inherently all the
other applications will get it so CI
it's super critical it's even more
critical when it comes to archetypes
because if you release an archetype and
it breaks something you break every
single component an app and we've
unfortunately done that a few times
and we get yelled at really quickly so
you want to avoid really want to avoid
getting yelled at and get getting a like
a thousand things on slack with someone
broke me and it's the archetype because
it's like instant and it ruins your day
and so the CI CD is most important
during of checking archetype versions
making sure if you're trying to bump a
patch or minor of archetype you're not
breaking any component and you know any
app so there CI CD kind of scale in
terms of how many apps that has to run
at once for to do this efficiently grows
where you're gonna have to you know run
dozens of apps in parallel for every PR
that you do and be ready for that but
that's kind of the best machine
intensive a way that we can solve it
that's not human intensive and so the CI
CD rules they're critical you can't
really go about reusability with without
and I feel there's gonna be a lot of
very large cost and so then you'll have
you'll end up having the different teams
being able to use the different pieces
and now these teams ensure that they're
not going to break each other and so we
can't like have this so as you go about
let's say implementing the the ability
to reuse and in terms of technical
sharing and then you go about being able
to add archetypes you're going to manage
dependencies and people can discover
components and you have a team of people
that you can rely on to help ensure that
they're going you're going the right
path there's still a fundamental problem
that that kind of comes about and I call
that kind of the ecosystem of reuse and
when you want to take reusability on as
an organization what we found is that it
has to permeate every single layer of
kind of management and development
because it affects absolutely everything
when people when you're going to build
something you now have to not think of
you know what's specific to you but how
can other people leverage of this when
you want to create a component you're
gonna have a discussion we're gonna have
discussion with other individuals and
other organizations
about can this health can this help them
or not
and when you estimate you might have to
do estimate you're gonna make let's say
a dozen new components you're gonna make
a page you might lose a day to have the
proper discussions and the thinking
upfront and so this really permeates
every layer and it's a change of
philosophy so you can't say I'm gonna
have reuse but I'm gonna build things in
silos or i'm gonna have reuse and I'm
gonna build my features and I'm not
gonna put them inside the organization
for everyone else to use I'm just gonna
put them in my app because it's faster
immediately things fall apart so even
with all of this in place it's still
fragile and only I feel the only way to
make it robust as if if people feel the
same way have this thing important to
understand what they're trying to do and
why they're doing it so it's really a
philosophy change and and how you build
moving forward and then there are still
challenges that we have not particularly
you know have really good solves for for
example when there's new libraries or
new technologies that are coming out
that you want to leverage and you want
to test out this is gonna work is it not
the benefits of the pros with everyone
we're using the same thing with everyone
in the same common platform how are you
able to innovate how are you able to get
teams to really try something new versus
not and so there are some challenges the
the fragility of if teams are not under
the same philosophy and and and what if
they're in a certain team people that
really want to experiment with a new
build system and if they go down that
route everything that they build cannot
be reused and they don't have to rebuild
everything from scratch but these are
kind of the challenges that you face and
that you have to kind of talk through
and and figure out a process and how to
do it and so that's kind of the way in
which we have been doing reuse and I
think we have five hundred something
components across 50 apps and a few
hundred engineers
we currently have three tenants that are
on kind of the electoral platform we
have
my grocery and a piece of Sam's Club and
where they're leveraging this reuse and
I think we have a decent system down
there's obviously room for us to really
help kind of continue the the philosophy
and pushing that forward improve our CI
CD some more but I think that this
general concept works thank you very
much
[Applause]